[موسيقى]
العلاقه كانت متوتره جدا لانه فور خروج
السودانيين قاده الحركه من المعتقلات بعد
المصالح الوطنيه في عام 77 طرحت مساله
التنظيم الدولي
وبالمقابل طرح الترابي والقياده السودانيه
انه لا يؤمنون بتنظيم دولي لحركه اسلاميه
عربيه ولكن يؤمنون بتنسيق عام بين حركات
الاسلام في العالم كلها العربيه
الباكستانيه والافريقيه وفي امريكا وفي
اوروبا وكان هذا بمصابه صدمه كبيره لانه
وفقا للائحه الارشاد عام 1948 ان
التنظيمات الاخوان العربيه هي فروع
للتنظيم الام في مصر فاعتبروا ان ذلك
تمردا من الحركه وخاصه من الترابي يريد ان
يكون مركزا وزعامه ووسمت هذه العلاقه طيله
السنوات
الفتره التي سبقت الانقاذ وبعضا من فتره
الانقاص وقام هنالك تنظيم اخر صغير باسم
الاقوال المسلمين بقياده الشيخ صادق عبد
الله عبد الماجد كان يبذل البيعه للتنظيم
الام في مصر وكان بعضا من التنظيم الدولي
ولكن تنظيم السودان لم يكن ابدا بعضا من
التنظيم الدولي
[موسيقى]
انا عشت في مصر فتره ودرست فيها
وهذه المساله كذلك تناولها كثير من
الباحثين ان الشخص يتخرج من الجامعه فيعمل
اخ المسلم في شركه الجماعه ويصلي في مسجد
الجماعه ويتزوج ابنه رئيس الشعبه واذا
تحرك حتى التاكسي يكون هو تاكسي الجماعه
فكان هنالك مجتمع مصري اخر صغير في حركه
الاخوان وهذه التي بدات منذ مرحله مبكره
اظن انه منذ ايام البنا منذ ان كان لهم
مدارس خاصه
ومعاهد خاصه للنساء وكانت له مستشفيات
خاصه وشركات خاصه وجيش خاص طبعا حار في
فلسطين فمنذ ذلك الوقت
نعم نعم هي حركه كبيره ولكنها كذلك تقيم
فاصل بينها وبين المجتمع المصري وهذا ادى
الى المواجهه التي حدثت مؤخرا
[موسيقى]